foreign
[Music]
night the search for answers as a
community Mourns a hate-fueled tragedy
10 killed in a
met by white supremacy this event was
committed by a sick demented individual
who was fueled a daily diet of hate and
renewed calls for Action this also calls
for a national response Finland and
Sweden announced intentions to end their
neutral status it is a historic decision
that we will join NATO how it could
forever change the power dynamic between
Russia and the West left in limbo the
long waits for Ukrainian refugees to
Canada and the expedited process that is
anything bought and
[Music]
the song that has ukrainians around the
world celebrating an international
victory
[Music]
Colleen Christie
good evening thanks for joining us the
community of Buffalo New York is morning
tonight shaken demanding answers and
action in the wake of Saturday's
racially motivated mass shooting at a
grocery store that left ten dead the
suspect 18-year-old Peyton Gendron
pleaded not guilty after being charged
with first-degree murder dressed in
tactical gear and armed with an assault
rifle it's alleged the teen drove more
than three hours to carry out his
hate-fueled attack deliberately
targeting a predominantly black
community and live streaming the
massacre on social media 11 of the 13
victims were black and Shauna Shea
reports investigators are looking at a
hate-fueled Manifesto the teenager
appears to have posted online two days
before the attack
a day after a mass shooting the pain is
starting to set in
as residents of East Buffalo gather and
grieve praying for the ten who died at a
top Supermarket on Saturday gunned down
while getting groceries my 97 year old
father comes to shop here 18 year old
Peyton Gendron faces first degree murder
charges it's alleged he drove more than
300 kilometers to the store and carried
out a plan to kill laid out in a
Manifesto he was wearing body armor when
he was arrested after a shooting spree
why are we so hate it that's what I want
to know this is a predominantly black
neighborhood this is my home this is
called Cold Spring everybody know Cold
Spring in Cold Spring the area's only
Supermarket now a major crime scene in
this little area that are supposed to be
for us by us black owned including the
supermarket this was an attack on all of
us
this black attorney general was shouted
down as she spoke to the crowd and
nothing like this has ever happened so
we have a right to show different
emotions we can just be hunted and
killed simply because of the way our
skin color is for any number of reasons
because they have Skittles because they
were in the grocery store because they
were playing loud music
support came from all over the city it's
not about me it's not about you but it's
coming together and really bringing
support to a community
how did you feel when you heard about
these people being killed I was angry I
was mad
that I was hurt if white people aren't
actively anti-racist it's not going to
change 11 of 13 people shot in the
attack were black This Woman's
grandmother was home not at the store
accidentally or she would have been in
there so she would have been shopping
there yes
except you couldn't fight her bus
schedule to get right we will hunt back
DeWitt Lee is a dual Canadian American
citizen who twice ran to be mayor of
Toronto he lives here now racism picked
the wrong City because uh Buffalo New
York is not going to stand complacent
Buffalo's mayor called for hope we as a
community will rise again stronger than
before the gun that was used was legally
obtained but illegally modified as for
the suspect he was on Authority's radar
for some time because of what he'd
written in high school he's pleaded not
guilty and we'll be back in court later
this week Colleen
in Buffalo New York tonight thanks Sean
U.S President Joe Biden condemned the
heinous crime calling it a stain on the
soul of America New York Governor Kathy
hutchell labeled it an act of white
supremacy terrorism as Jennifer Johnson
reports the supermarket shooting has
once again renewed calls for tighter gun
control
New York's governor and others are
outraged the alleged Buffalo Shooter's
deadly Rampage was live streamed on the
platform twitch for almost two minutes
officials are warning the CEOs of these
Outlets of legal consequences if they
don't crack down on sites promoting hate
and racism don't they have a
responsibility they have resources they
have technology keywords show up they
need to be identified someone needs to
watch this and to shut it down a
preliminary investigation shows accused
murderer 18-year-old Peyton Gendron
repeatedly visited social media sites
promoting white supremacy and race-based
conspiracy theories this was Pure Evil
it was straight up racially motivated
hate crime this mass shooting has again
rattled a nation already dealing with a
daily dose of racial and hate-fueled
attacks and gun violence America's
greatest national security threat the
statistics have been showing us there's
more of a threat of domestic terrorism
and violence than International
Global terrorism President Joe Biden is
calling on the nation to put an end to
Violent extremism we must all work
together to address the Hate That
Remains the stain on the soul of America
but even now there is little discussion
on new gun control laws even though
America has seen 198 mass shootings so
far this year Buffalo's mayor is urging
Congress to finally pass a sensible gun
control bill after all of these mass
shootings that have taken place in this
country for different reasons year in
and year out let Buffalo New York be the
last place
that this kind of mass shooting happens
despite the epidemic of gun violence
it's been 25 years since the federal
government has passed any law limiting
the spread and use of guns in America
Johnson Global News Washington
to Europe now where the invasion of
Ukraine has triggered an historic shift
among Russia's Nordic neighbors both
Finland and Sweden have officially
announced they'll seek to join NATO the
two Nations cited Russia's War as key
reasons to join the Western defense
Alliance as Dan Spector explains their
moves are a major rebuke of Vladimir
Putin despite his own threats against
them
Finland making history at a Sunday press
conference in Helsinki announcing a
seismic policy shift that could change
the power dynamic between the west and
Russia we kind of trust anymore that
there will be a peaceful future next to
Russia with our own that's why we're
making the decisions to joining NATO
Finland shares a 1300 kilometer border
with Russia but until recently polls
showed Finns didn't have much interest
in joining the defensive Alliance of 30
countries the invasion of Ukraine a game
changer support for a NATO bid
skyrocketed it is a historic shift in a
foreign policy security orientation
hours after finland's announcement
Sweden took its turn making history
prime minister Magdalena Anderson
announcing her country will end 200
years of neutrality to launch the
process of joining NATO Sweden stayed
neutral even through the second world
war the war in Ukraine proving to be the
ultimate Catalyst
Vladimir Putin has cited Ukraine's
desire to join NATO as one of the
reasons for The Invasion last week the
Kremlin war in Finland that tying itself
to the alliance would carry consequences
but if halting NATO expansion was one of
the goals of the war it's backfired in
spectacular fashion this is a major
miscalculation by Putin good afternoon
the moves came as NATO foreign ministers
met in Berlin members of The Alliance
expressing strong support for both
Sweden and finland's bids to join on
Twitter Canada's foreign affairs
minister encouraging other member
countries to make the process quick but
joining NATO requires unanimity and not
all members were immediately on board
NATO member turkey is demanding certain
guarantees its foreign minister
criticized Finland and Sweden for
supporting Kurdish groups it designates
as terrorist organizations I'm confident
that we will be able to address
the concerns that turkey has
NATO Secretary General Yen stoltenberg
also saying Russia's war in Ukraine is
faltering and that Sweden and finland's
efforts to join NATO will show that
aggression does not pay Dan Specter
Global News Montreal
Canada has promised to be a safe haven
for ukrainians fleeing Russia's Invasion
especially when they plan to join family
who live here but even though Ottawa has
expedited the immigration process
obtaining a Visa is proving to be an
arduous and lengthy task as Heather
York's West explains families say their
loved ones have faced lengthy weights in
limbo
we cannot leave her alone in Poland Ina
baranov was desperate to get her mother
home having already endured the
terrifying early days of the Russian
invasion alone in Odessa she was
stranded in Poland waiting for a
Canadian visa no no I thought it's gonna
be fast because my mom she is first 85
years old second she has place to go
because she got depressed you know
because she said how long how long the
baronovs did not have an answer after
several weeks waiting with her mother
veronoff's husband ran out of vacation
time so she had to fight a Warsaw to
take his place
Alexandra aslanova and her two young
daughters were facing a similar
frustration in Germany her sister's home
in Winnipeg had beds and toys to welcome
them but after submitting three Visa
applications only one had come through
it's so cruel when when you give a visa
to one family member but not another the
worst thing is that there's nobody to to
talk to you have to deal with some
website run by uh a company which is not
even the part of the government what I
saw there was really shocking and
embarrassing and I felt like somewhere
between nausea and like I wanted to cry
Alexander polowski found this scene at
Canada's Visa processing office in
Berlin after trying to help a Ukrainian
woman navigate the system he was
surprised to find the place inaccessible
to those who had traveled there and some
of them had been telling me that they
are sleeping in their car like not in
the street like in sleeping bags but in
their cars directly in front of this
office and that one one lady multiple
people actually told me that they were
had been staying there for three days
pawlowski says the Ukrainian woman he
helped left the office empty-handed that
day only able to get an appointment
online a month later in Paris Ina
baranov's mother was finally able to get
her visa after a lawyer became involved
Alexandra aslanova's daughters
eventually received their visas to after
several weeks of unexplained delays
finally allowing these families to begin
new chapters now that their limbo is
over at last Heather urich's West Global
News
unity in question coming up how the
Alberta premier's leadership review
could cause a deeper divide
and the serious and growing problem of
Instagram hacking
with the results of Jason kenney's
leadership review just days away his
political future hangs in the balance
and as Sarah comedina reports even if
the Alberta Premier survives his United
conservative party caucus may remain
firmly divided
Alberta Premier Jason Kenny is confident
he will remain at the Helm of the United
conservative party as he waits for the
results of review of his leadership of
the political party he formed less than
five years ago he promises he won't call
an early election if he wins I have
given zero consideration
to a quote snap election I think it
would be dumb political scientist Lori
Williams says Kenny is facing questions
about his leadership Integrity his
ability and if this process is fair it
could have a significant significant
impact on his ability to lead his caucus
to connect with those who have raised
questions and and challenge his
leadership and it could lead to a split
Kenny's opponents have raised concerns
with the membership list UCP MLA Brian
Jean who is seeking to replace Kenny if
he's toppled says more than 4 600
memberships admitted to the party were
paid for by only eight credit cards he's
filed a complaint with elections Alberta
our understanding is that multiple
parties made complaints with elections
Alberta in relation to this and and we
understand they're investigating it
according to correspondence obtained by
the Canadian press elections Alberta is
investigating allegations of possible
illegal bulk buying of party memberships
the UCP says the claims are false we
will receive a result built on on
Wednesday
there's absolutely no indication that
that result will settle the questions
that are swirling around Jason Kenney in
order to stay on Kenny will need to win
by 50 plus one Premier stelmac and
Redford both got 77 and they were only
able to hold on to power for a few
months on Facebook Jean says there needs
to be way more than 50 percent to have
party confidence results will be
announced Wednesday the premier hopes
everyone will respect them and then it
becomes another sort of chapter in in
the fight for the the leadership and the
control of the United conservative party
Sarah comedina Global News Edmonton
David Milgard has died Milgard spent 23
years in prison for the 1969 rape and
murder of Gail Miller a nurse in
Saskatchewan he was 16 years old when he
was sentenced to life in prison his
conviction was thrown out with the
introduction of DNA evidence and was
released in 1992. it took another five
years years to be officially exonerated
in 1999 he was awarded a 10 million
dollar compensation package from the
federal government he dedicated his life
to advocacy to prevent other
miscarriages of Justice David Milgard
was 69.
I had Instagram warning how easily you
can be hacked and how hard it is to get
help
you're watching global national
for many people Instagram is an
important business marketing tool one
they've spent years building well now
there's been an explosion in the number
of hackers infiltrating the social media
platform it means users lose access to
their accounts and the sensitive
information they contain and as Sean of
Shea reports restoring them is anything
but easy
I would say like five years it took me
to kind of get to the point where I was
Alicia Davies is a Toronto model with
more than 5 800 followers on Instagram
it's her online portfolio key to getting
work until she accidentally clicked an
Instagram message one day and everything
changed that fast that fast in minutes I
was locked out hackers took her
Instagram account hostage and she felt
helpless for weeks the hackers sending
messages to her contacts pretending to
be her trying to persuade them to invest
their money she tried repeatedly to get
the account restored says she did
everything to reach Instagram's parent
company before calling us I tweeted
Mehta I tweeted Instagram I got in touch
with Facebook and I'm at a loss this man
had the same experience I'm not getting
any responses back keikwasi spent well
over a week trying everything to get his
account back he was worried I'm also a
member of that Canadian Armed Forces
Reserve I have pictures of my chain of
command I have messages between myself
and my chain of command and my Instagram
messages that I don't want this person
to continue to have access to right now
Instagram users around the world are
experiencing the same thing the company
told Global News it takes violations
very seriously using what it called
sophisticated measures to stop Bad
actors in their tracks before they gain
access to accounts as well as measures
to help people recover their accounts
other people will be falling
after our interview Alicia used a
YouTube video and stayed up all night to
get the account restored stop by my
phone stopped by my laptop and I just
waited for the approval to come through
the same day we called Instagram for
keokwazi his Instagram was back with new
security measures in place like
two-factor authentication I feel relief
what are the lessons you learned out of
all this lock your stuff up I'm just
relief despite what Instagram claims
about taking hacking seriously and
trying to help users get accounts back
Alicia Davies isn't convinced they're
making enough effort this is a crime
business and Instagram have got nothing
they're not putting anything to stop it
Sean Shea Global News
next how television meteorologists are
sharing more than just forecasts and the
winning Eurovision song that's become a
victory anthem for Ukraine
with extreme weather events on the rise
it's all but certain climate change is
here yet despite the evidence to many
the crisis can feel distant and Abstract
it's also hard to think about what we as
individuals can do about it and that's
putting a new onus on news
meteorologists to change that perception
Cameo razavi explains
the warning signs are here and there are
more of them than ever
continue to cut our emissions
decades Canadians have been warned about
the deadly impacts of climate change
and yet the climate crisis as urgent as
it is can still feel abstract and
hopeless but that's changing I will be
the first to admit that I was really
hesitant to even come anywhere near to
talking about climate change that's Alan
seals the chief meteorologist at the
local NBC station in Mobile Alabama one
of the most conservative places in the
U.S like many TV weather casters he
wasn't always the first to connect the
nightly weather forecast to long-term
climate Trends there are two different
things but there is no debate whatsoever
that the Earth is warming it is
impacting Our Lives Commerce
transportation agriculture so these days
he regularly includes climate
information in his weather report making
climate change understandable and
relatable to the average person that
shows you slight warming around here and
that's why your air conditioning unit is
probably running more frequently TV
weather casters are uniquely positioned
to bring climate change information to
their local audiences first of all most
of them are scientists themselves and
the only scientists at the public sees
on a regular basis they already have
this ability to break down complex
equations and Mathematics and physics
into simple statements it's having a
major impact as weather casters help
people understand the local impacts of
climate change it helps people to
understand climate change isn't only a
distant problem it's actually a problem
that has already come home to roost in
our communities now I truly believe that
when people are smarter we are healthier
you live longer you live better when you
have solid information to help you live
your life and plan your life information
that's increasingly important in a
rapidly warming Planet Cameo razavi
Global News Vancouver
and that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm Colleen Christie we
leave you tonight with a victory for
Ukraine on the international stage
and here they are
[Applause]
[Music]
what a moment Ukraine's kalash Orchestra
was the big winner at the annual
Eurovision song contest propelled by the
overwhelming support of Van votes the
band song Stefania is an Ode to the
front man's mother but it has become
somewhat of an Anthem for ukrainians in
the face of War traditionally the
winning country hosts the Eurovision
final in the following year and
President Vladimir zielinski is vowing
that will happen in a post on the social
media app telegram he says our courage
impresses the world our music conquers
Europe next year Ukraine will host
Eurovision zielinski says he wants the
competition in Mary upoll a city that's
endured merciless attacks since the War
Began
thanks for watching Donna Friesen will
be back at the anchor desk tomorrow have
a good night and here's more of the
kalash orchestra
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]